millions of genetically modified
mosquitoes could be released in Florida
basically to stop two very painful viral
diseases so I'm gonna do a little
reading here because I want to get the
science right cuz as I said I got two
bright people with me the dang the
dengue am i right dengue dengue and the
chikungunya yes ganya chikungunya viral
diseases coming okay pretty good so far
our growing threats in the US and with
global warming with climate change
spreading tropical diseases farther from
the equator storm wins cargo ships and
humans carry these viruses to southern
cities in the u.s. like the Florida Keys
so there's an explosion of this in
Florida right now there were no vaccines
or cures for either of these two
diseases and many more people now are
being basically are afraid of being
bitten by a GMO organism because that
Mac could start a whole other set of
problems anyway so more than 130,000
people have signed a change.org petition
trying to stop these GMO mosquitoes from
being released yeah we're good okay I'm
feeling pretty good about this anyway
the head of the Florida medical
entomology laboratory had this to say I
think the science is fine they
definitely can kill mosquitoes but the
GMO issue still sticks as something of a
thorny issue for the general public I'm
on their side and that consequences are
highly unlikely but to say there's no
genetically modified DNA that might get
into a human that's kind of a gray
matter okay so as you can tell by my
lead-in to this this is not my
department
so I want carrot can you clean up this a
little bit because there's a couple
issues here there's general fear of
diseases there's GMO stuff yeah there's
fear of disease there's fear of
genetically modified organisms and I
think that the the link between the two
we need to make sure is clear so the
reason that these GM mosquitoes that
have been developed in a UK lab and have
been successfully deployed I think in
Brazil and I think in one other area in
South America or Central America and
acts
did reduce the population the way it
works is that these genetically modified
mosquitoes have been modified to contain
some sort of protein some sort of coding
region in their DNA that allows them to
successfully mate with disease-carrying
mosquitoes or any mosquitoes of the
species that they're trying to target
and produce offspring that's not viable
so basically it it kills off the
population because these modified
mosquitoes can't persist so the idea is
we can't kill billions of mosquitoes
right but what we can do is release
mosquitoes that it through through
reproduction will end up dramatically
reducing the population of
disease-carrying mosquitoes so this to
me is a question of again kind of first
world privilege this we've talked about
GMOs a lot yeah and I obviously have
been very kind of outspoken about being
Pro GMO yeah and one example that I
would use is that there there was a rice
that was developed called Golden Rice
and golden rice was developed in in an
effort to provide nutrition that wasn't
present in certain parts of the world
and Greenpeace because of their fear of
GM technology successfully stopped
golden rice from being delivered and it
has been estimated that literally
millions multiple millions of people
could have lives could have been saved
if Golden Rice had been released and I
worry that this is the same kind of a
situation where because people don't
understand the science they're willing
to cock-block something that could
prevent a lot of people from suffering
really debilitating illnesses right okay
so you did a much better job of the way
I presented it so there's sort of two
things happening here one the GMO is in
general people fear sort of irrationally
almost everything we eat is genetically
modified right our bananas all right are
there no such thing as regular bananas
anymore
70 and 90% of the foods on your grocery
store shelves if you're not shopping at
a place that specifically caters towards
that it has some ingredient that's
genetic right and that doesn't mean that
it's killing you or doing anything bad
there's literally there's no evidence
out there at all that it has any
negative effects on health or human
safety the only concerns that most
people the only legitimate concerns
about GM technology are crop
concerns their concerns about spreading
crops and taking over other fields and
you know when you develop something
that's a crop that's drought resistant
and that you know is really Hardy yes it
might not die if and when you try to
kill it right so okay so then that that
gets me to my next question which is I
think most people have this conflation
between GMOs and Monsanto yeah and
Monsanto has strange business practices
related to the crops and what people can
use season after season and things I'm
not even asking you a question there but
I feel like no no I mean I feel like
it's it's very necessary to separate to
parse those two hours yeah I think that
like in the hands of a company like
Monsanto that seeks only a profit motive
I mean it's dangerous but I love the
Golden Rice analogy there's another
really recent one that I love so in in
Uganda children are deficient in vitamin
A and it's got a real you know stunting
problem with the growth of children a
lot of them are you know experienced
vision problems because they're so
deficient in vitamin A and so you
mentioned bananas they're now trying to
or they're able to actually modify
bananas so they're a lot higher in
vitamin A and to prevent these sorts of
you know this malnourished means in
Uganda and it's amazing and I think that
the minute we start vilifying you know
in the broad sense genetically modifying
organisms I think it's super dangerous
right and going back to mosquitoes like
the males that they're talking about
modifying aren't even the ones that bite
right yeah the modified mosquitoes are
the non biting mosquitoes they're just
worried that a handful of females might
make it into the crop and that a handful
of those female mosquitoes might bite
you but why do I give a [ __ ] if a
genetically modified mosquito bites me
that maybe contains like a handful of
proteins that prevent it from being able
to make viable offspring I would be much
more concerned about getting bitten by a
mosquito carrying chikungunya right why
you said that well with total confidence
- okay so try to help me understand this
so the people that don't like GMOs in
this case what they would argue I guess
is that we're gonna create a super
strain of mosquitoes that eventually we
won't be able to control I mean is that
that's what their argument I don't think
that they can articulate what they're
afraid would happen I don't think that
there is a valid scientific argument for
what would happen I think it is that
kind of whoa we don't know because we
haven't tested it and it could have some
sort of runaway consequence that we
can't foresee in the future
and I get that but isn't that with all
science I could use caution when we
think about that and yes you can look
historically at drugs that were
developed that people took that then
caused really big problems and had to be
taken off the market because we didn't
do enough testing I totally understand
that concern but at the same time would
you throw the baby out with the
bathwater would you never take another
pill again right and that's that's the
irony of these people that believe in
science half the time and then don't
believe it the other hats yes before
it's like people were just afraid of
what they don't understand yeah so is
this just one of those issues I mean
again the way I presented this thing up
top I don't really get all of this stuff
but I I'm trying to do stuff like this
just so that people that have a few
minutes can get a little bit of
something on this but is this just one
of these things where people just won't
take the time to learn about so that's
why it's never discussed like that's why
this is the type of story that doesn't
make it to CNN or to Fox or whatever
because there's just like a lot of big
words and you have to think about it for
a second so people just don't talk about
it yeah and I think that people's
opinions are easily swayed by clickbait
headlines too I don't think that those
help the cause but yeah I mean I think
people need to this is like our world
you know and it's rapidly changing now
more so than ever before people need to
take the time to to read up and I think
what you said is an important point
because we in the media have to take
responsibility for this problem too I
mean if we are the ones presenting these
stories just like the article that we
read leading up to this to this segment
a lot of the headlines are gonna be like
GMO mosquitoes millions of you could be
released in your neighborhood danger
danger and that's how we present it of
course it's going to make people afraid
but if we prevent it if we present it in
a really balanced way I think people
will understand that this kind of
technology which might be scary because
you don't understand it can have really
positive implications yeah all right
well on that note we will link to the
story that we're talking about down
below so you can actually do some more
research and learn a little something